déroulera le cinquième des filets
principal des forces navales russes
comme les voiliers en bois les barques à
rames et les galères de l'époque de
pierre legrand le long des quais palais
et squares passeront des vedettes des
corvettes et des frégates d'acier des
sous marins à propulsion diesel
électrique et des sous marins nucléaires
montreront la puissance leur puce un
détachement de l'aéronautique navale
défilera dans le ciel au dessus de la
capitale maritime de la russie depuis
325 ans la marine russe assure la veille
permanente des frontières maritimes de
la russie elle est protégée montre au
monde entier sa fidélité au serment
prêté et au pavillon de saint-andré
toute l'histoire de la flotte russe est
la chronique des actes héroïques
l'histoire de la vaillance désintéresser
du courage de l'aptitude au combat et de
la maîtrise de l'art de la guerre des
marins russes
c'est l'histoire des grandes découvertes
géographiques des succès scientifiques
techniques industrielles du pays et du
labo du labeur inspiré des savants
concepteurs ingénieurs et constructeurs
de bateaux cette série de succès
commence par la première victoire en
mère de la jeune flotte russe sur les
suédois près du cap de good cette
victoire constituerait une avancée
morale pour la flotte russe son baptême
du feu
quand elle se découvrit capable de
s'opposer à la flotte d'une grande
puissance maritime depuis plus de 300
ans passés et toutes ces années les
marins russes ont été et demeurent un
motif de fierté pour le peuple
la fleur de l'armée et de la nation
toute une pléiade de commandant et de
chefs de guerre talentueux a été
instruite dans la marine parmi eux des
amiraux tels que spirit of ushakov sénia
vinh lazareff kornilov nakhimov
kuznetsov gorshkov
pendant les années de la grande guerre
patriotique la marine russe a participé
à toutes les opérations offensives et
défensives
les marins soviétiques ont détruit plus
de 2500 navires ennemis assurer le
transport de 10 millions de personnes et
de plus de 100 millions de tonnes de
fret
ces derniers temps et jusqu'à nos jours
elle continue à remplir ses missions de
présence navale sur les océans à
conquérir la zone arctique à tester de
nouveaux matériels et armement ainsi en
décembre 2020 pour la première fois dans
la pratique de l'instruction des forces
sous-marines de l'océan pacifique
un sous marin nucléaire de type 955 a
procédé au tir réussi de 4000 mise 4
missile balistique boulava depuis les
eaux de la mer d'okhotsk les systèmes
d'armes ont tous atteint les cibles
d'exercice désigne un et les un
événement significatif de l'année
d'instruction 2021 a été l'expédition
polaire menée sur l'archipel
françois-joseph au cours de laquelle on
était mené des exercices tactiques par
des sous-marins l'aéronautique navale et
les unités de gardes côtes dans le cadre
des exercices pour la première fois a
été réalisé la remontée à la surface
simultanée de trois sous marins dans un
secteur de taille restreinte des tirs
pratique de torpilles ont été effectués
pour pratiquer des trous dans la
banquise
la marine russe actuel constitue une
arme et équilibrée elle peut agir dans
quatre éléments simultanément sous l'eau
en surface sur la terre ferme et dans
les airs elle comprend des forces sous
marines et de surface une aéro dit une
aéronautique navale une infanterie de
marine et d unité de garde-côtes
les nouvelles technologies dans la
construction navale russe les nouveaux
principes physiques sur la base
desquelles sont conçus les nouveaux
types d'armements et de matériel
militaire
les nouvelles règles tactique et
stratégique de la marine russe combiné
au grand professionnalisme au dévouement
et à la fidélité à la patrie de nos
marins témoigne d'une chose la russie
est défendu de façon fiable sur les mers
et les océans
[Musique]
votre attention s'il vous plaît ici
saint pétersbourg aujourd'hui va se
dérouler le cinquième grand défilé des
forces navales russes
conformément à la tradition établie
aujourd'hui pour la cinquième fois des
marins des flotte de la baltique de la
mer noire de la mer du nord de l'océan
pacifique de la flottille de la mer
caspienne ainsi que des bases navales de
la fédération de russie en syrie
participeront au grand défilé navale à
l'heure actuelle l'amiral nikolaïev men
of commandant en chef de la marine russe
est arrivée au quai du commandement de
la forteresse pierre et paul où sous
forme de vidéo conférence les
commandants de flotte lui rende compte
de l'état des forces et les troupes
navales et du dispositif prévu pour le
défilé est maintenant en direct de
severomorsk damas principal de la flotte
de 10 sur vos écrans rediffusion en
direct depuis bâle tisc base principale
de la flotte de la baltique
ce commandant de la flotte de la mer
baltique camarades commandant en chef de
la marine la flotte de la mer baltique
est prête pour le défilé noces à tov
commentant la flotte de la mer baltique
réponses reçues en direct de saint
pétersbourg avec saint pétersbourg
sébastopol ville légendaire couverte de
la gloire des exploits héroïques des
marins forteresse imprenable sur les
rives sud de la russie
le commandant de la flotte de la mer
noire
le vice-amiral osipov commandant de la
flotte de la mer m'a reçu et maintenant
le port de nice puisque base principale
de la bnrf lotis de la mer caspienne 10
amiral peskov
comment dans la flottille de la mer
caspienne reçu la rediffusion se
poursuit aussi depuis la base navale
russe de tartous sur le territoire de la
syrie
[Musique]
capitaine de vaisseau dobrinine
commandant le groupement de la marine
russe en zone maritime éloigne reçu
la présentation des rapports au
commandant en chef de la marine est
achevée celui-ci se dirige maintenant
vers le président de la fédération de
russie est commandant chef suprême des
forces armées de la fédération de russie
pour lui rendre compte que les forces
sont prêtes pour le défilé navale
oh
[Musique]
avaler surtout la marque auprès des
cantons
[Musique]
début du défilé navale
la salve tirée par une batterie de la
forteresse pierre et paul donne le
signal du lancement des célébrations de
la journée de la marine russe
le commandant chef suprême des forces
armées de la fédération de russie
le ministre de la défense et le
commandant en chef de la marine se
dirige vers les navires placé en rade de
la forteresse pierre et paul pour le
défilé
[Musique]
la tradition de procéder à des défilés
navale remonte à plus de 300 ans à
l'époque de pierre premier
on considère généralement que le premier
d'entre eux avoir été organisée dans le
respect de rituel précis est celui du 9
septembre 1714 il s'était déroulé en
l'honneur de la victoire des marins
russes dans la bataille d'un good contre
les suédois en 1723 pour le deuxième
anniversaire du traité de nice table sur
décision de l'empereur fut lancé une
nouvelle tradition la cérémonie de
passage en revue des navires disposer
dans la rade de cronstadt par le
commandant chef de la flotte et son
accueil par le chef du défilé sur le
navire amiral la première revue fut
effectuée par pour pierre premier qui
utilisait alors une chaloupe dit ancêtre
de la flotte russe
nous célébrons aujourd'hui le cinquième
anniversaire de la renaissance de la
tradition du défilé de la marine pour la
troisième année consécutive le défilé de
navires sur la neva a à sa tête le
vaisseau de ligne pas le travail de 54
cas non restauré dans un chantier naval
historique le pôle d'havas et le premier
vaisseau deux lits mis en chantier est
construit en 1712 sur la cale de
l'amirauté de saint pétersbourg il servi
plus de 20 ans dans la flotte et a
participé à plus de six campagnes navale
dans la grande guerre du nord deux fois
durant ses années de service l'emploi
l'empereur a tenu lui-même le pavillon à
son bord ce vaisseau est le symbole de
la préservation des traditions navale de
la succession des générations du courage
et de l'héroïsme des marins russes
la vedette présidentielle s'approche de
la corvette lance missiles grad souillac
ville de sciage de la classe boyan m de
la flottille de la mer caspienne
sous les ordres du capitaine de frégate
kirill alexandrov
grâce john irish
le chef suprême des forces armées russes
adresse ses félicitations à l'équipage
le 7 octobre et le 20 novembre 2015 dans
le cadre de l'aide militaire apportée
par la russie à la syrie la corvette
grazia ce au sein d'un groupe de quatre
navires de la flottille de la mer
caspienne a procédé à la première
utilisation combat des missiles de
croisière calibre basée en surface prêt
au défilé le grand navire de
débarquement allié gursky gauriac sous
les ordres du capitaine de frégate
maxime les flots les navires de cette
classe constitue à l'heure actuelle la
base de la flotte russe de débarquement
ils ont pour mission d'amener les unités
de débarquement avec leur matériel de
combat sur tous types de littoral ils
peuvent également être employé pour le
transport de troupes de fret et la pose
de barrage de mines
c'est
la vedette présidentielle se dirige vers
la corvette stalking commandée par le
capitaine de corvette à retour garibian
cette corvette fait partie d'une phase
de navires multi rôles de zones côtières
et a pour mission d'assurer un régime
opérationnel favorable dans les mers
proche des opérations de combat contre
l'ennemi en mer et les groupements de
troupes terrestres opérant sur le
littoral elle embarque des missiles qui
découragent et redoute désarmement canon
et orpik multifonctionnel
[Musique]
la vedette présidentielle s'approche de
la frégate admiral cas ça tourne
ce navire est placée sous le
commandement du capitaine de frégate
alex est allé à boston
[Musique]
l'alignement des navires s'achève par le
sous-marin à propulsion diesel
électrique ronstadt il est commandé par
le capitaine de frégate maxime paul
evans
[Musique]
le cronstadt plongé à une profondeur de
300 mètres et se déplacer à une vitesse
élevée en plongée par l'ensemble de ses
caractéristiques techniques ce
sous-marin relève de la quatrième
génération de sous-marins nucléaires
le président de la fédération de russie
a achevé le passage en revue des navires
positionner en rap de l'année va et se
dirige vers le quai de l'amirauté
[Musique]
les états
d'accord
[Musique]
c'est
et
[Musique]
non
je vois là
[Musique]
leur salut au drapeau
devant les unités rassemblés pour le
défilé les groupes de porte drapeau
présente le drapeau national de la
fédération de russie est celui de la
marine selon la tradition pour saluer
les mérites des marins russes dont la
défense des intérêts nationaux est hissé
sur la tour de l'amirauté le symbole du
grand défilé navale à savoir le pavillon
de poupe du sein genre de saint georges
du navire de l'hymne glorieux azoff le
navire de ligne azoff sous le
commandement du capitaine de vaisseau
lazarev remporta le 8 octobre 1827 dans
la bataille navale de navarin une
victoire sur cinq navires ennemis
[Musique]
oui
atlantico
par occase de l'empereur nicolas 1er
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
la marine russe le navire dont azoff
suite ornés du pavillon de poupe de
saint-andré
[Musique]
le président de la fédération de russie
et commandant en chef des armées
vladimir poutine camarades bar un
officier marié officiers généraux
amiraux cher d'anciens combattants chers
concitoyens citoyens de la russie
félicitations pour la fête de la marine
fête grandiose par sa rigueur et aussi
par sa beauté marque toutes les
générations de ceux qui ont défendu les
frontières maritimes de notre pays et
cette fête
auch est chère au coeur de notre peuple
car la vaillance le courage l'audace des
pionniers a tracé la route de notre
patrie sur les mers a illustré sa
grandeur nous saluons et vénérons notre
marine
nous sommes fiers de son histoire riche
des noms glorieux qui jalonnent son
histoire tous ceux qui à différentes
époques se sont battus et ont vaincu au
nom de la patrie
ceux qui ont fait des découvertes
géographiques importants qui ont apporté
des connaissances précieuses et
irremplaçable pour la russie et le monde
entier
tout cela suscite la fierté et la marine
remplit des missions tout à fait
diverses
elle est remplie de façon tout à fait
honorable et nous fêtons déjà son 325e
anniversaire la russie a su très
rapidement s'imposer parmi les grandes
puissances navales
le monde et elle a parcouru un chemin
énorme depuis la modeste chaloupe de
pierre legrand jusqu'au dernier grand
sous marins nucléaires sa portée sur les
mers proches comme sur les les maires
éloigné font qu'elle est capable de
d'utiliser des armements de pointe sans
équivalent mots partout en tout point du
globe
aujourd'hui la marine russe a tout ce
qu'il faut pour garantir la défense de
notre patrie nos internationaux
elle est capable de découvrir tout
navire en surface ou en profondeur qui
s'approcherait de notre pays ait résisté
à tous les coups qui peuvent lui être
portées elle est aujourd'hui
pratiquement dans toutes les zones
maritimes du monde au nord au sud et
elle est partout présente le service de
la mère n'a jamais été un service facile
et ça fait toujours partie de l'élite et
on sait que les marins sont toujours
ceux qui ont su s'illustrer sur tous les
fronts sur toutes les mers que ce soit
la flottille de la caspienne ou les
grands mères comme la mer noire la mer
du nord se sont pacifiées et aujourd'hui
on va voir encore ce défilé et je suis
certain que grâce au professionnalisme
et à l'audace et à la rigueur des
équipages des combattants des garde
côtes
la marine russe et son pavillon le
pavillon de saint-andré renault demeure
toujours préservé qui ne sera jamais
ternie
et limo première occase qui avait
indiqué le statut de la marine et son
pack doyon a pour obligation de ne
jamais céder
bonne fête avant la marine russe
ouah
[Musique]
les navires de surface de la marine
russe viennent de faire leur entrée sur
la neva dans quelques instants
ils poseront en rang devant le quai de
l'amirauté le grand défilé navale se
distingue des autres défilés navale
données à l'étranger en ce que les
navires russes ne sont pas statiques et
aligné comme dans la pratique des
marines étrangères
ils défilent devant les tribunaux le
climat changeant de la baltique impose
des conditions particulières la houle le
vent en rafales changeant souvent de
direction l'étroitesse du cheval et du
chenal tout ça imposent leurs règles de
navigation
compte tenu de ses caractéristiques
variées et des particularités de
navigation dans l'enceinte de la ville
de même que la houle et les passages
étroits ou au niveau des ponts en
position ouverte
ils doivent tous passés devant la
tribune principale
à l'heure dite en respectant la distance
fixe est parfaitement alignés l'écart
admissibles ne doit pas excéder quelques
secondes
c'est une mission complexe qui exigeait
une discipline stricte une grande
expérience de navigation et un grand
professionnalisme qui est révélateur de
la maîtrise des équipages
les navires se distingue par le
déplacement d'eau leur vitesse leur
motorisation des navires à turbine à gaz
à propulsion diesel ainsi que des
vedettes sur coussin d'air vont
participer à ce défilé
[Musique]
c'est le début du volet naval du défilé
le défilé des navires sur la neva et au
vert et par le patrouilleur anti
sabotage naquit mauvaise porteur du
drapeau de la fédération de russie
à son bord deux jeunes élèves des écoles
navales nakhimov qui porte le nom du
fameux rend le russe pavel naquit
mauvais au coeur de voir les mènent les
élèves de l'école naquit move
remplissent leur mission avec honneur et
dignité
ils servent la patrie et porte toujours
avec fierté le nom de sean glorieux de
la marine russe pavel nakhimov 20
le pavillon de la marine russe est porté
par la vedette
on tisse un potage yuna made by law
marion la vedette a été nommé en
l'honneur du mouvement patriotique russe
se lancer dans les traditions des
meilleures organisations de jeunesse de
dépend de la patrie depuis sa fondation
en 2016 le mouvement est réuni plus de
huit cent soixante dix mille enfants et
adolescents de toute la russie
[Musique]
le pavillon de la marine russe est porté
par la vedette en dise un potage ep 429
le fond blanc avec la croix de
saint-andré bleus se déploient au dessus
des pots des navires russes depuis le
xviiie siècle
le croisement des quatre angles au
centre du pavillon symbolise entend le
lien entre les mers européennes de
russie aujourd'hui le pavillon de
saint-andré flotte sur les océans
montrant ainsi que la marine russe est
prête à défendre les intérêts de l'état
en tout point du globe
[Musique]
le défilé se poursuit avec des vedettes
de débarquement sur coussin d'air de la
classe et serna la partie histoire du
défilé est ouverte par la vedette de
débarquement alexeeva rénove porteuse de
la de pierre le grand en centre
de la marine russe
la passion du futur empereur pour la
chose marine et les sciences navales n'a
qu' lors d'une promenade se voile sur
cette petite chaloupe vers ensuite les
victoires d'apr actionner greg ushakov
nakhimov les grandioses découverte
géographique et la création d'une flotte
océanique résolument nouvelle
tout avait commencé donc par cette
petite chaloupe
[Musique]
à bord de chalands de débarquement ivan
parce qu une réplique d'une vedette
rapide de l'époque de la grande guerre
patriotique
la barge de débarquement mkl vingt sept
les vedettes de ce type e malgré leur
faible tirant d'eau furent de véritables
navires de guerre pluviaux et sont les
seuls bateaux de la marine soviétique à
avoir participé aux combats de la prise
de berlin
des passionnés de l'association de
soutien à l'étude de l'histoire
militaire epoca on trouvait des éléments
authentiques de cette barge légendaire
est pur donc à en faire une réplique
exacte
[Musique]
nous voyons maintenant le patrouilleur
une armée yates baltique y porter du
pavillon de la flottille prix unitaire
de denver
les marins de la flottille avec des
unités de la 101e division sur repoussé
l'offensive des troupes allemandes et
romaine qui lancèrent une contre
offensive mais ils furent les premiers
pendant la deuxième guerre
nous voyons maintenant le patrouilleur
p400 62 porteur du pavillon de combat du
bataillon de patrouilleurs de la 2e
brigade des navires de la flottille ou
d'ab inbev
lord coe d'alexandre nevski lui a été
remis le 14 novembre 44 pour la
vaillance et le courage qui ont été
manifestées dans les combats pour la
libération de belgrade
non
voyons maintenant le patrouilleur p400
62 c'est un patrouilleur illustre et qui
a participé à la libération de belgrade
l'équipage du patrouilleur entier
sabotage volet était d'y animer porte
fièrement le pavillon de combat du 5e
régiment de la garde de d'artillerie
côtière de la marine même le régiment
était décoré de l'ordre d'alexandre
nevski pour l'exécution exemplaires de
ces missions de combat contre les
envahisseurs allemands lors de la percée
de la défense et la libération de la
prusse orientale défilé la navette anti
sabotage une armée yates dagestan à de
la flottille de la mer caspienne un
portage du pavillon de la 154e brigade
de fusiliers de marine à l'ordre de l'ex
entraîneur qui numéro un est remis au
chef du bataillon d'infanterie de marine
le lieutenant ivan van pour avoir
repoussé les attaques menées par un
régime en asie soutenus par des chars
dans ce combat en othe 42 dans un coup
de dieu dont le bataillon de vendre ban
a détruit sept chars et a tué plus de
200 soldats ennemis
[Musique]
vous voyez maintenant passer des navires
de déminage le premier d'entre eux est
le dragueur de mines
rt 57 commandé par l'ancien de vaisseau
de première classe à l'excès frolov le
plus jeune commandant du navire de se
défiler
l'expérience de la grande guerre
patriotique et des conflits d'après
guerre a montré l'importance de disposer
de navires de ce type la marine ayant
besoins en équipements de déminage
puissant et nombreux les dragueurs de
mines d'aujourd'hui pour laisser
question de leur mission de déminage
sont équipés de détecteurs de mines de
différents types par contact en
profondeur électromagnétiques et
acoustique pour se défendre et détruire
les mines détecter ces navires sont
équipés de canons et de fusils
mitrailleurs de gros calibre 1
ces dernières décennies les dragueurs de
mines ont rempli un certain nombre de
missions de déminage dans les eaux du
golfe de finlande est et de la mer
baltique au cours de la pose du gazoduc
nord stream du golf de loeb et du
secteur côtier de la mr2 karam
vous voyez maintenant passer le dragueur
de mines pavel konnov il est commandé
par le capitaine de corvette alexis
machine covan depuis qu'il est en
service ce dragueur de mines a parcouru
plus de quinze milles nautiques 15 mille
milles nautiques
il est nommé en l'honneur du commandant
de la section de mineurs de la 1ère
brigade de dragueur du secteur de
défense maritime de tallinn le m pavel
canova le 26 août 40,1 près de l'île de
hollande
hoogland il fut le premier à se jeter
sur le transporteur en feu entraînant
derrière lui ses subordonnés sous les
bombardements incessants de l'aviation
et aryan l'incendié fut liquidé le
navire son chargement et l'équipage
sauver
[Musique]
le défilé se poursuit avec le dragueur
de mines de nouvelle génération
alexandre au beau corps renommé en
l'honneur du héros de l'union soviétique
alexandre robocop participants de la
grande guerre patriotique comme
commandant d'un groupe de vedettes blême
des dieux 2e bataillon de nader garde
côtes
le navire est commandée par le capitaine
de corvette à sergei projet d'ailleurs
ce navire envers une nouvelle page dans
le développement des moyens de déminage
de la marine il est équipé d'un système
unique robotisée de détection des
destructions des mines et assure la
sécurité de l'équipage contre tous les
types de mines de l'ennemi sans pénétrer
dans le champ de mines
les appareils tractée et sous marins
autonomes peuvent détecter et détruire à
distance des mines aussi bien dans les
autres sur les fonds c'est le plus grand
navire en fibre de verre
monolith en mode
[Musique]
dans les autres la neva fait son
apparition un groupe de navires et de
vedettes lance-missiles de la flotte de
la baltique en tête du groupe navigue la
corvette rapide lance-missiles
dimitrovgrad appartenant à la division
de la garde des navires lance-missiles
de la flotte de la baltique
la corvette est commandée par le
lieutenant de vaisseau maratka ni
pauvres ces navires sont destinés à
détruire des bâtiments de surface et les
commandos de débarquement et là sur la
défense anti aérienne des groupes de
navires contre les appareils volant à
basse altitude et protège les autres
navires contre les attaques des forces
mobiles ennemis les corvette laa
classement l'ia doter de missiles
antinavires france qui est restent parmi
les plus puissantes au monde
[Musique]
le long du lac et de l'amirauté naviguer
la toute nouvelle corvette
lance-missiles odintsovo son commandant
le capitaine de frégate série borissenko
par leur conception et leur potentiel de
combat les corvette lance-missiles de la
classe car à kout sont sans équivalent
dans le monde en fonction des missions
qui lui sont impartis un seul navire de
ce type est capable de détruire un grand
bâtiment de surface est un site côtier
de grande dimension il accomplit ses
missions de façon autonome ou au sein
d'un groupe de navires de combat autres
ces missiles de haute précision calibre
dont l'efficacité au combat a été
prouvée ces navires sont équipés d'un
système avancé de défense antiaérienne
de navigation et de lutte électronique
il est prévu de doter les navires de
cette classe de missiles et personicx
ircon qui sont pratiquement invulnérable
aux systèmes actuels de défense
antimissile la coque compacte du navire
abrite une puissance de feu énorme
hollande
le défilé continue avec le passage de la
corvette lance-missiles et le nid dole
qui porte le nom d'une ville située en
république du tatarstan
le navire est sous les ordres du
capitaine de frégate sergei 2 cenco
cette corvette lance-missiles de la
classe bouillonne m représente une
nouvelle génération de navires de la
marine russe
construit par les chantiers navals de
selena dolls que la particularité de ce
navire est le rêve revêtement de la
coque et la conception spéciale de sa
forme qui réduisent considérablement la
probabilité de détection de ce navire en
mer ce navire est équipé d'un système
d'armes en carrière de canon de 100 mm
ainsi que de lance missiles de haute
précision à lancement vertical calibre 1
qui tirent des missiles de croisière à
capable de détruire des cibles maritimes
et terrestres
vous voyez maintenant un groupe de
batteries york côtiers de la classe
mannequin est appartenant aux forces
gardes frontières du service fédéral de
sécurité
ces patrouilleurs côtiers construit au
chantier naval bump elles peuvent
atteindre la vitesse de 90 km heure leur
vocation et la protection des frontières
nationales en mer la défense des eaux
territoriales et des ressources
naturelles dans la zone exclusive
économique la fédération de russie
ils peuvent être utilisés également pour
la lutte contre la contrebande et les
transports maritimes et légaux en ces
temps de service les équipages de ces
patrouilleurs seul et surtout des
maîtres principaux alberte glas des
chefs et vassili ya au rove interpellé
38 intrus ayant pénétré dans les eaux
territoriales et environ 200 personnes
qui ont violé le régime de garde
frontières ces patrouilleurs ont
participé en maintes reprises à la
protection de sites sensibles et
d'événements sociaux politiques et
sportifs l'honneur d'être parmi ceux qui
prennent part au grand défilé navale
revient à ses équipages reconnus comme
les meilleurs équipages parmi tous les
patrouilleurs gardes frontières du
service fédéral de sécurité à saint
pétersbourg et la région de leningrad à
l'issue de l'année 2020
nous voyons maintenant le patrouilleur
orengo et commenté par constater qu aux
lèvres et qui est porte le nom de la
ville située dans la région de iamalo
nenets
c'est patrouilleurs sont destinés à la
protection des régions côtières de
navires de combat ceci en mission
autonome et au sein de groupes tactiques
de navires ils peuvent atteindre la
vitesse de 30 noeuds
[Musique]
actuellement dans le ciel de la
politique sont formels et patrouilles de
l'aéronautique navale dont l'instant ils
vont passer au dessus de la neva ils ont
décollé de différents aérodromes et
malgré leurs performances et
l'éloignement la météo ils peuvent
atteindre la zone pourrait passer
ensemble au dessus de saint pétersbourg
en faisant preuve de leur maîtrise de
vaud l'ain c'est une mission compliquée
est vraiment délicate à la rade de
cronstadt nous voyons de grands
bâtiments de débarquement de haute mer
la grande particularité de ces navires
et la présence d'une rampe de cooper
basculante nos savons maintenant le
navire commandé par anthony collins
ce navire à maintes reprises a rempli
des missions au sein du groupe de
navires en méditerranée où il a
participé aux opérations dans en
république arabe syrienne
il est tard mais deux tours l2 canon à
haute vitesse de tir ainsi que de lance
missiles grad
ce qui lui permet de détruire le
personnel neutraliser la défense côtière
et assurer l'auto défense
non voyons maintenant le grand navire de
débarquement et autres morgan recommandé
par contre sur le viol
il est mis en service en 2017
les grands navires de débarquement sont
des bâtiments de haute mer a destiné au
débarquement des commandes sur tous les
types de littoral
ils sont armés de canons et de
différents moyens
ils peuvent embarquer deux hélicoptères
[Musique]
les tribunes salue la coupe grey machisu
les autres du capitaine de frégate oleg
pottas pauvres et durant les années de
la grande guerre patriotique l'escorteur
d'escadre grimm achi a fait face aux
envahisseurs nazis au sein de la flotte
du nord
aujourd'hui c'est la tête de série d'une
de la classe modernisée qui garantit la
défense de la zone côtière et est
destiné aux combats de haute intensité
contre les forces ennemies qui
agissaient sur la côte
ils sont armés de lances missiles
calibré et de lance-missiles redoutent
ainsi que des torpilles et de roquettes
[Musique]
vient ensuite le destroyer de l'otan sm
vice-amiral kulakov sous les ordres du
capitaine de frégate stanislav rose
shocking
les destroyers de lutte asm constituent
actuellement la principale force de
lutte anti-sous-marine ils sont destinés
à accomplir des missions dans des zones
éloignées et océaniques au sein du
groupement opérationnel le principal
armée modiste destroyer est un lance
missile anti sous marin capable de
détruire un sous marin à la distance de
90 km 1 ce destroyer a participé en
maintes reprises à des patrouilles au
sein d'un groupe en deux navires de
combat de la flotte du nord le long de
la route maritime du nord en faisant
escale et sur les îles de la terre à
françois josef et l'a assuré la sécurité
de navigation le long de la route
maritime du nord et a pris part aux
manoeuvres tactiques interarmes plateau
de putorana
et voici le croiseur lance-missiles
maréchal oustinov sous les ordres du
capitaine de frégate entre écrivains aux
ordres se croisera destinée à détruire
des grands navires de surface et
développement entière de navires des
appareils tu attaques aériennes des
sites côtiers
il est peut accompagner des convois et
des unités d'hébergement en mer ce
navire à sept reprises a été qualifié le
meilleur navires de la flotte du nord en
il a été décoré de la plus haute
récompense collective dans la marine le
calice de bord le croiseur moskva et
varyag appartiennent à la même classe et
et son lien navires amiraux des flotte
de la mer noire et du pacifique et le
participe aujourd'hui aux défilés navale
de sébastopol et vladivostok
[Musique]
nous voyons les patriotes rapide almaz
sur les autres du capitaine de corvette
entrée didenko sa fonction principale
est d'effectuer des patrouilles dans les
eaux territoriales russes d'assurer la
protection des frontières maritimes
nationales de ressources maritimes et de
lutter contre la pêche illégale la
contrebande et le transport illégal de
fret et deux personnes en accomplissant
ses missions le patrouilleur almaz a
parcouru plus de 72000 milles nautiques
il a interpellé trente deux intrus dans
les eaux territoriales et 106 personnes
qui ont violé le régime des zones
frontalières 1
l'équipage du patrouilleur a participé à
deux reprises à des exercices
internationaux à maintes reprises ce
patrouilleur a été reconnu comme
meilleur navires au sein des forces
carte de frontières
[Musique]
le défilé continue avec le passage d'un
groupe tactique de grands shows marin à
propulsion diesel électrique qui
représente toutes les flottes
les sous-marins volkov et d'être pavlov
kamtchatski
il représente la flotte du pacifique le
sous-marin vladikavkaz représente la
flotte du nord sous les ordres du
capitaine de frégate harton bondarenko
le sous-marin krasnodar sous les ordres
du capitaine de frégate stanislas chute
ce qui représente la flotte de la mer
noire
la combinaison entre furtivité
acoustique et distant de détection des
cibles à dotation moyens de navigation
des plus modernes ainsi qu'un système
automatisé d'informations et de gestion
assure aux sous marins de la classe
varsha verne cas un gros potentiel de
combat l'armement principal de ces
sous-marins est constitué de six tubes
lance-torpilles qui tire des torpilles à
haute probabilité de destruction et
d'une rampe de lancement de missiles de
croisière calibre les sous mariniers de
toutes générations ont toujours été de
grands professionnels plein de courage
et d'amour envers leur patrie durant les
années de la grande guerre patriotique
les sous mariniers ont accompli plus de
1200 mission de combat ils ont coulé
plus de 100 navires de combat et 300
bâtiments de transport et demi pour un
tonnage total de plus d'un million de
tonnes
plus de 6000 sous mariniers ont été
décorés d'ordre et médailles 21 sous
marine et se sont vu remettre le titre
de héros de l'union soviétique
pour la première fois depuis la période
d'après guerre
le sous-marin krasnodar qui navigue
actuellement dans la rade cronstadt a
effectué un tir de missile de croisière
calibre et détruit des sites de
terroristes sur le territoire de la
république arabe syrienne au 21ème
siècle
les opérations de combat vont se
déplacer de plus en plus en profondeur
dans les mers et les océans
c'est pourquoi la force principale des
forces navales russes ainsi que des
marines de guerre d'autres puissances
maritimes sera constitué deux sous
marins dotés d'armes hautement efficace
capable d'évoluer donc toutes les
régions océaniques et de protéger
l'activité maritime de leur pays
la russie dispose d'un grand potentiel
scientifique et technique d'une
expérience de longue date en matière de
conception construction et emplois des
sous marins par les sous mariniers
hautement qualifiés ce qui lui permet de
déterminer les grandes orientations du
développement des sous marins dans le
monde
[Musique]
et voici une frégate des forces navales
de la république de l'inde
elle est baptisée tard cash ce qui
signifie littéralement karkwa la frégate
est commandée par le capitaine de
vaisseau marc eichmann qui publie cette
frégate est le cinquième navire de la
série construits en 2012 pour la marine
indienne au chantier naval yant arts de
la ville de kaliningrad ces frégates ont
bénéficié d'une modernisation de leur
armement et d'une amélioration des
caractéristiques techniques
elles sont également équipés de missile
brahmos de conception russo indienne
pour participer au grand défilé navale
la frégate a traversé l'océan indien et
l'océan atlantique
[Musique]
c'est
la fédération de russie accueille une
escadre des forces navales de la
république islamique d'iran sur le
commandement du contre-amiral match
d'abou omar hamadi dans la rade de
cronstadt navy de la frégate sa rade
sous les ordres du capitaine de frégate
hms astute billets cette frégate a été
construit dans le chantier naval iranien
de la ville de bandar abbas en 2008 18
et de la casse de frégate mood la
frégate saccades et d'armes et de
missiles de croisière antinavire adhère
capable de détruire des cibles à une
distance de 200 km ainsi qu'un nombre
important de moyens d'artillerie et de
défense antiaérienne elle est destinée à
assurer la sécurité de navigation des
bâtiments iraniens et la lutte contre la
piraterie dans les eaux internationales
des golfe d'aden et d'oman grâce à
l'occasion du grand défilé navale la
frégate est accompagné du porte
hélicoptères markram avec ces appareils
embarqués
[Musique]
le défilé dans la rade de cronstadt
s'achève par le passage de la frégate du
soul fille car des forces navales du
pakistan le navire est commandée par le
capitaine de vaisseau ahmed ibrahim anne
van la frégate sofica a été mise en
service en 2009 elle a reçu le nom de
l'appellation d'une épée à deux pointes
liés à la vie aux actes du prophète
mahomet en février 2021 en mer d'arabie
à l'initiative des autorités
pakistanaises ont eu lieu des exercices
n'avoir navale au bloc
militaro-politique ammann 2021 pour la
première fois dans l'histoire des
relations bilatérales des navires de
combat et l'infanterie de la marine
russe y ont participé
un nombre un groupe de navires russes
composé de la frégate amiral gourevitch
et le patrouilleur dimitri watch hrw ont
mené des exercices conjoints avec les
navires pakistanais pour renforcer la
coopération militaire au profit de la
sécurité et de la stabilité dans le
monde au cours de ces exercices
les militaires des deux pays ont procédé
à un échange d'expériences dans la lutte
contre la piraterie en mire en mer dans
les régions à au trafic maritime
le défilé aérien s'approche en 2021 nous
célébrons le 105e anniversaire de
l'aéronavale russe le 17 juillet 1916 4
hydravion russe qui avait décollé du
porte-avions tu portes hydravion orleans
à affrontèrent dans le ciel de la mer
baltique quatre avions allemands
abattant deux d'entre eux sans subir de
pet à leur tour et cette date du 17
juillet 1916 est considéré comme la date
de naissance de l'aéronavale russe le
voile aérien du défilé commence dans le
ciel de saint pétersbourg groupe
tactique d'hélicoptères de transport et
de combat multi-rôles mi-8 mtv commandés
par le lieutenant colonel yav guinée
daoudov
ensuite
des hélicoptères comme of qu'à 31
accompagné de deux hélicoptères
embarqués modernisée de lutte
anti-sous-marine kamov ka 28
la patrouille est placée sous les ordres
du lieutenant colonel igor ni crasson
dans le ciel de saint pétersbourg vol un
groupe d'hélicoptères embarqués de
reconnaissance et d'attac qu'à 52 18
commandé par le pilote d'essai alexandre
pas bien
et voici des avions de transport
antonoff à n 72
ils sont particulièrement apte à
projeter des armements et du matériel
dans des zones difficiles d'accès ces
appareils sont capables de décoller et
atterrir sur des pistes sommaires
enneigées ou couvertes de glace
la patrouille tactique et sous les
ordres du lieutenant colonel du riz cote
la vienne comme le ciel de saint
pétersbourg accueille deux hydravions
beriev be 12 ces appareils ont fait
preuve de leur fiabilité ont battu 46
records mondiaux
les hydravions sont emmenés par le
lieutenant colonel vladimir nikolov
suit une patrouille d'avions de lutte
anti-sous-marine moderniser les
légendaires iliouchine il 38 n la patrie
tactique est emmenée par le commandant
vladimir clé chauffe
[Musique]
m
voici des agents destinations spéciales
tu peux left tu 154m et tu pollet 134 à
4 équipés de systèmes sophistiqués ces
appareils sont utilisés pour la
formation des pilotes de toutes les
armes de l'aviation navale et dans un
large éventail de missions
les avions sont sous les ordres du
commandant me file fait jacking
[Musique]
l'aviation de lutte anti-sous-marine
représenté par une patrouille de tup
oleffe 142 les avions des plus grands
les plus rapides parmi tous les avions
de lutte anti-sous-marine à
turbopropulseurs la patrouille et sur
les ordres du lieutenant colonel dénis
ce panneau
[Musique]
suit une patrouille de chasseurs
multirôle support sur 30
sm de génération 4 + plus la pâte rue et
emmenés par le lieutenant colonel pavel
bozotti
[Musique]
au dessus de la neva passe des chasseurs
de l'aéronavale su qu y su 27 la patrie
de chasseurs sous les ordres du
lieutenant colonel al estime koutchoumov
[Musique]
voici les chasseurs embarqués sur consul
33 sous les ordres du lieutenant colonel
sergueï rami d'aullène
le défilé aérien continue avec le
passage de chasseurs multirôle embarqué
mig 29k sous les ordres du commandant
andré kaspersky
dans le ciel de saint pétersbourg des
bombardiers tactiques à géométrie
variable ce qu'ont su 5 sur 24 sous les
ordres du commandant de mitry lebedev
au dessus de la neva passe des chasseurs
intercepteurs tout en 1031 les meilleurs
au monde
en 2021 deux avions de ce type
ravitaillés en vol ont survolé l'article
au dessus du pôle nord géographique
[Musique]
le groupe est commandée par le
commandant alexandre pas devoir trancher
le volet aérien s'achève par le passage
d'avions d'attaqué au sol sukhoi su 25
cl s un panache tricolore dans le ciel
de saint pétersbourg le blanc le bleu et
le rouge du drapeau national russe la
patrouille est sous les ordres du
lieutenant colonel vladimir bordas saufs
[Musique]
le grand défilé navale est terminée vive
les forces navales qui défendent les
frontières maritimes de notre patrie
[Musique]
on
prête au défilé garder les lignes mans
par compagnie
oh
vingt prix turgot
porter armes alignement à droite
en avant marche
[Musique]
le défilé des troupes des forces navales
et aux verts par les porte drapeaux de
la compagnie de la garde d'honneur qui
porte le drapeau national de la
fédération de russie et le drapeau des
forces navales à savoir le pavillon de
saint-andré
la première à défiler et la compagnie
mixte de l'école navale nakhimov de
saint pétersbourg les jeunes élèves sont
sous les ordres du capitaine de frégate
à l'excès d'eau brad g20 devant les
tribunes défilent l'avenir des forces
navales une compagnie mixte du carnaval
des cadets de cronstadt tous les promus
de ce corps de cadets poursuivre leurs
études dans des écoles navales et
s'apprête à servir dans la marine russe
la compagnie est sous les ordres du
capitaine de frégate
roslan locaux 20 devant les tribunes
défilé bataillon mixte du centre de
formation et de recherche des forces
navales
c'est un puissant complexe à vocation
pédagogique et scientifique qui est
dirigé par le vice amiral victor sokolov
en qualité de fleurons de la science
navale
ce centre forme des spécialistes de haut
niveau des commandants des navires et
d'unités navales le bloc de fils hier
formation à la faculté de commandement
et des états-majors de l'académie navale
est amené par les chefs des facultés le
capitaine de vaisseau grille horaire net
ce qui est le capitaine de vaisseau
dimitri serebrov devant les tribunes
défi le bloc d'officiers informations
dans le carnaval pierre le grand
sous les ordres du capitaine de vaisseau
alexandre morgen
fait son apparition était vachement
composée d'officiers informations à
l'institut navale pour les techniques
riche d'une histoire de deux siècles et
les placer sur les ordres du capitaine
de vaisseau que tout cela kostenko et
voici le détachement composé d'élèves
officiers du corps à laval pierre
legrand sous les ordres du capitaine de
corvette alexandre iv l'air tchouk
civile un détachement de l'institut
navale polytechnique avec à sa tête le
capitaine de corvette andrés trelles
nico 20 de nos jours c'est le seul
établissement navale à former des
spécialistes en génie militaire pour la
marine russe et le ministère de la
défense
le défilé à pied continue avec le
passage du détachement d'honneur du
centre de formation de l'infanterie de
marine sous les ordres du lieutenant
colonel michael civière co et voici un
bloc mixte du mouvement patriotique des
jeunes yuna mia
à sa tête le commandant et réserve l'un
des mis en cause mines les jeunes qui
défilent représente une vingtaine
d'écoles de saint pétersbourg et ils y
ont suivi la formation militaire à bord
des navires de la base navale de
cronstadt le défilé se termine par une
prestation de la musique des forces
navales
sous la baguette du capitaine de frégate
valentyn l'igas tchenko le grand défilé
navale est terminée vivre les forces
navales de la fédération de russie qui
défendent les frontières océanique et
maritime de notre patrie
[Musique]